very often when on this program we look
at clips from Congressional hearings
particularly clips of Republican members
of Congress who have an inflated sense
of self-importance and ego trying to
make themselves look like they are smart
and well prepared it's merely disaster
porn and what I mean by that is it's not
particularly instructive it's sort of
like wow they looked really dumb but
there's not that much to learn from it
today I have a very different example
for you that is extraordinarily
instructive and we're going to link it
actually to this recent report on the
origins or oranges of covid from the
Department of energy but before I even
do that let's talk about what we're
talking about a radical and repugnant
Republican Congressman Matt Gates
was called out yesterday in real time
for citing Chinese propaganda
now what happens here is extraordinarily
instructive with regard to confirmation
bias and not only the willingness but
the eagerness of these right Wingers to
accept any Source uncritically if it
confirms what they already believe so
let's take a look at this clip this was
a moment during the house armed services
committee where Matt Gates tried to sort
of gotcha call and call who's the U.S
defense under secretary for policy and
talk about the azov Battalion getting
access to American weapons uh Colin call
says I don't have any evidence of that
and Matt Gates says well what about this
and it turns out that it is over Chinese
propaganda you will also notice if
you're watching this clip that some of
the folks sitting in the audience really
seem to be enjoying this okay so let's
take a look and then we'll talk about it
is the azov battalion
less weapons
uh not that I'm aware of but
if you have information
consent to enter into the record the
global times investigative report that
uh indicate that talks about training
it's uh from the Atlantic council's
digital forensics research lab uh citing
the azov Battalion was even getting
stuff as far back as 2018. without
objection so ordered any reason to
disagree with that assessment is this
the I'm sorry is this the global times
from China no this is
well that's what you read
yeah would that be a reason uh I I as a
general matter I don't take beijing's
probably no no yeah just tell me if the
allegation is true or false I mean I
don't have any evidence one way or the
other as a general matter I don't take
beijing's propaganda at face value fair
enough I would agree with that
assessment April
the global times okay is a daily tabloid
newspaper published under the auspices
of the Chinese Communist party's
Flagship paper the people's daily it is
overtly Chinese propaganda now
it a a tabloid Chinese propaganda
newspaper might occasionally publish
things that are true but understand that
Matt Gates doesn't actually care about
that Matt Gates didn't have any idea
that he was repeating over Chinese
propaganda there and the the sort of
story of the day here
um is confirmation bias now okay Matt
Gates probably later went and yelled at
whatever staffer put that in his package
of stuff for the day and said I'm being
ridiculed the the country over for what
I just did and somebody's gonna somebody
is is gonna be fired or going to be
admonished for it but if you look at the
clip you can tell not only does Matt
Gates not know anything about the source
he doesn't care about the source and
this is a perfect example of how the
modern Republican party the Maga people
Etc they Embrace any source that tells
them what they want to hear or what they
already believe and they don't care
about the validity uh of the source the
analogy here is the Department of energy
report on covid Origins we talked about
this extensively yesterday on the bonus
show well the bonus show where you want
to make money yeah everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad
and we made an incredible amount of
money on yesterday's bonus show talking
about this the department of energy put
out a report about the origins of kovid
and says our assessment is it was an
accidental leak from a lab in China and
in the report the department of energy
says this is a low confidence assessment
and it's based on not super reliable and
very limited uh evidence and all of a
sudden the same right-wingers who for
three years have been saying I don't
trust anything the government tells us
about the origins of covid now they
trust a department of energy assessment
about the origins of covet why is the
Department of energy even assessing this
well that's a fair question but the the
real point is
they are now uncritically accepting a
government report about the origins of
kovid after saying for years you
couldn't trust government reports about
the origins of covet why because it
happens to be a report
admittedly low confidence admittedly
with with sketchy and limited data that
confirms what they already believe and
that's what this is fundamentally all
about one other this is like a bonus
clip from yesterday's hearing here is
friend of the show Eric swalwell
slamming Matt gates for bringing to the
hearing someone he met at a gun club
who had been charged with killing a
family member in April of 2019. this
isn't a joke okay this is this is where
we are today take a look one of the very
first committees the very first
Committee hearing of this Congress
Mr gates after we had all agreed on what
the committee's plan was going to be it
was going to be voice voted everyone
agreed Mr Gates wanted to offer an
amendment to say the Pledge of
Allegiance that's great every single
person on our side supported that
now I don't think he really genuinely
cares about saying the Pledge of
Allegiance no but he wanted to do it
again to own the libs and to see if we
would vote against it we didn't
but who did he bring in here to say the
Pledge of Allegiance right who did he
parade in here in a uniform
somebody that he met at a gun club he
said locally okay Mr sicolini had the
crazy idea that maybe we should vet the
people who come in here make sure
they're not insurrectionists Mr
McClintock
I am not kidding you Mr McClintock said
well it's not like we're gonna invite
somebody who committed murder
no he literally said that it's not like
we're gonna invite somebody who
committed murder
okay well
who did Mr Gates bring he brought
Corey Beekman
Corey Beekman in 2019
was in a standoff with the Michigan
Police
after he was arrested and charged with
murder assault with it to intent to
commit murder and two counts of felony
firearm possession
the family of the victims said Mr Gates
doing that it was like getting a dagger
stuck in our heart again we were
infuriated when we first saw it I was
disgusted with the whole thing
that's why there's a trust deficit here
you'd pull off a public stunt to try and
own the libs and what you did was you
brought in a guy who allegedly shot
two people and killed one of them yep so
a very very bad day yesterday for Matt
Gates and this is exactly what we
expected with Republicans controlling
the House of Representatives humiliation
after embarrassment after humiliation
after embarrassment and they are
certainly not disappointing
one of our sponsors is zipx nicotine
toothpicks don't you think it's time you
stopped putting smoke and vape oils in
your lungs zippix toothpicks are a
convenient way to curb the nicotine
Cravings zippix toothpicks are super
discreet you can use them anytime
anywhere smoking and vaping aren't
allowed including flights sporting
events in restaurants they're available
in six different flavors with options of
two and three milligrams of nicotine if
you're not a nicotine user zipix also
offers caffeine and b12 infused
toothpicks zipx has already helped tens
of thousands of customers ditch the
cigarettes ditch the Vapes they might be
able to help you too if you're a smoker
or a vapor give zipx toothpicks a try
your lungs will thank you go to
zipxtoothpix.com today save 10 with the
code pacman10 at checkout out just
remember you must be 21 or older to
order the link is down below